Most people don't realize you can build a clock console that tells you the brutal truth about your idea of a 40-way six months on the wrong thing.
Here's how to set it up.
You drop your idea in one paragraph and it splits it into four people who fight it out.
The believer makes the strongest case for why this works and who desperately needs it.
The skeptic attacks every week point.
The reason people won't pay, the competitor you forgot, the part you're lying to yourself about.
The investor cares about one thing.
Whether real money would actually show up in how fast.
Then the judge reads the whole fight and hands you one verdict.
And this is a part that matters.
And it remembers your idea so tomorrow you can come back and ask what change.
People are running ideas through this before they toast single friend.
And catching the fatal flaw in ten minutes instead of six months.
I put together these exact four aging counsel in every problem.
So come and roast.